Come
to think of it, I don't remember locking the door when I went out. Beatrice didn't have a thief inside, so I don't think you need to worry about it, but I
wonder if she'll come pick me up if I lock her up.
You might jump out
just to see it, right?
Back Bag It looks
like you don't have a brain.
Frederico
: Well, I'm Frederick.I'm Frederica Baumann, who used to take care of me here before.
I was just
taking a break, and when I returned after being called back by Ram, the mansion was empty.
When I returned, the kitchen and the garden of the mansion were in a terrible
state.I wonder if it was a compelling reason.
You can't run the mansion alone, so
you relied on Frederica?